hello this video shows the Coursera
setup steps including your account on
Coursera steps to enroll students and
how to monitor students learning
progress to access the admin console
sign in to Coursera with your
credentials Coursera provides several
dashboards at different stages of the
program to track the progress of
students the admin dashboard and the
program admin pages show the data for
your members learners and completers
this sample data shows you how students
are progressing through your learning
programs a student status may be active
inactive or at-risk in the invitations
tab you can track and see the status of
the invitations that you've sent to the
students you can also resend invitations
if needed to add and invite individual
students complete the following steps
open the Coursera program for the
associate cloud engineer track click on
the invitations icon enter the
individual's full name and email address
and click send invitation the import
members feature enables you to add and
invite multiple students at a time to
import members start by creating an
invitee list create a spreadsheet with
column names exactly as shown full name
email external ID the values in the
external ID may be left blank download
the student data as a CSV file here are
the steps to import students using your
CSV invitee list from the invitation tab
click import members follow the
instructions in the Coursera dialog when
you complete the import members step the
students receive an automatic invitation
email from Coursera your students are
now ready to start learning on Coursera
by opening the google cloud etu
invitation email with the subject line
you're invited to learn on Coursera in
the email students may click join
program to join the associate cloud
engineer track the student can then
enroll in the first course Google cloud
platform fundamentals core
infrastructure we have reviewed steps
for your account setup in Coursera
student invitations and learning
progress monitoring
hello and we'll want to preview the
interactive hands-on labs platform
called quick labs and how you actually
be practicing a lot of the things that
you can learn here inside of real Google
cloud platform accounts but you don't
need your own credentials those drugs
can be provided for you so let's take a
look at how the lab spot is set up on
the right hand side is your instructions
pane for the actual lab now this labs in
meta lab it's all about quick labs in
general but whatever your course is this
is where the instructions for completing
the lab are gonna take place so you
always want to keep this prompt open now
once you actually click start lab a
provisioned instance of the Google cloud
platform complete with any additional
instances or say you're working with
vm's if there's something that the lab
provider wanted you to have it's
actually gonna be created inside of this
lab instance for you which is a great
it's a sandbox instance now once you
notice I click start lab I have 15
minutes to complete this lab I promise
you that the timer's are gonna be
associated with additional padding for
the labs that you're gonna do this isn't
going to me it gets tickets 15 minutes
or something about five minutes it's now
as I mentioned before you have the
username and password and a project ID
what I'll ask you to do now is click on
open Google console and once you've
opened Google console you'll be asked to
sign in with your email now the key
thing here is if you use Google
resources before immediately it'll start
typing in your personal email I do it
all the time make sure you go back to
your lab credential screen and copy and
paste the username that's auto-generated
for you this can be unique for you and
it's actually going to be unique for
every lab that you run so you're
creating a new student account for each
lab that you run copy and paste that
password it's gonna be different from
mine so don't worry about copying that
down click Next in your browser paste in
that password accept the terms don't
worry about setting up a secondary phone
number accept the terms of the Google
cloud platform and once you see a screen
that looks like this then you're good to
go
make sure a key tidbit is this is your
project selector it should be this
auto-generated quick labs alphanumeric
if you should happen to see something
that says either select a project or if
you see something it says quick labs
resources you act
I click on this and make sure to select
your alphanumeric quick labs ID and then
go ahead and I'll hit open once you're
within here you're good to go so follow
the instructions for the rest of the lab
it's gonna guide you through what
products and services that you're gonna
be working with you can access the menu
of products and services in the upper
left hand corner here or if it's a lab
that's working with cloud shell all the
way up here is the button to activate
cloud show which will bring open that
terminal instance for a Google cloud
platform last few things back here
you'll see that our timer is
automatically running still once you're
completed with the lab you're done with
it now make sure in order to get your
completion stats properly recorded click
on end lab you'll be faced with a prompt
that says are you all done
once you click end lab your project any
datasets anything that you've been
working with inside of this sandbox
project is going to be deleted so make
sure if you have any queries that you're
running or any interesting notes that
you have saved inside of the Google
cloud platform quick labs account that
you copy and paste those and save them
somewhere else perhaps in your own
personal Google cloud platform account
or somewhere locally on your machine and
once you've clicked end lab then you can
enter a feedback for the lab and you can
continue moving on so again quick recap
don't want to think key things remember
is in order to get those credentials
here on the left hand side you have to
click start lab which again kicks off
the timer and there's no way to pause
once the lab has started but again keep
in mind you have multiple attempts and
lastly click on end lab when you're
ready to completely complete out the lab
that you've been working on that's it
good luck with the labs and enjoyed
[Music]
what are the next steps here are the
next steps to get started with the
associate cloud engineer track first
login as a Coursera admin you should
have received a link via email next
create a CSV file with the names and
email addresses of students and enroll
them in the program conduct study jam
one for the students who have enrolled
study jam one is a workshop aim to
introduce your students to the program
and learning platforms review faculty
FAQ if you have any questions here is a
checklist that you can use to keep track
of all the activities you'll need to
complete the checklist can be accessed
from the faculty FAQ page to summarize
your goals are as follows as a learner
within the associate cloud engineer
track timeline complete the architecting
with GCP specialization on Coursera
finish extra practice with quick labs
use the available 100 percent discount
for faculty on the associate cloud
engineer certification exam as a coach
for your students within the associate
cloud engineer track timeline conduct 3
study jams for the associate cloud
engineer track ensure that all students
complete the architecting with GCP
specialization on Coursera within the
timeline prescribed in the Coursera
program invitation ensure that all
students prepare for the associate cloud
engineer certification exam and use the
available discount with the Google cloud
associate cloud engineer track help your
students reach high and lead them to a
cloud first world